[Music]
[Applause]
when you ride that bus keep it on your
mind when it guarantee Cloudant look
like rain ever go down in Georgia I'm
gonna walk and talk and tell everybody
about it in New York put on and lose
Anna walk until been on the top of town
yeah call it and y'all did it he did see
there he appeared even got to know my
line
preying on the ground and it won't keep
feel gonna kick me a painted rider you
go heal in New York City
it'll be there you're never even got to
do my line
young there be no male
[Music]
top me up in Holland
under the Harlem send stop me oh there's
two colors enough in Harlem the bride's
all his tools in all of them and old
Satchmo's still swim where all the cats
are still not there they're beaten out
those ribs and the follow water it'll
give you a red people if yes you get red
beans and rice it's very nice
[Music]
they say the neon lights are bright on
road we they say there'll always magic
[Music]
when you're walking down Main Street and
you eat the glitter of the ride off but
you ain't nowhere they say the girls are
something they'll slide here on hallway
they looking good y'all but looking at
them the skills of me the booze
[Music]
how
they say I'm gonna get to be hound bus
and try to make it home one day
[Music]
[Applause]
ballsy sound I'm saying
until a stone ball we talking about
he'll probably Oh I'm gonna have my name
up in lights down around Times Square
somewhere out here oh no way looking
good
Oh Broadway feeling good
[Music]
looks like a choice
I found a fan she tried out
voices voices on herself voices wrong
voices to the heart self versus down a
stairwell in New York just got a place
in New York
[Music]
- the
around
[Music]
I just gotta
to
[Music]
yes like they own the place
we got the airport city
slow dance for baby got the police
[Music]
cute
[Applause]
[Music]
on the night
lays it down
[Music]
[Applause]
the mama pajama roll latter day that she
went to the polling station when the
Papa found out he began to shout and
started the investigation it's against
the law it was against the law I what
the mom I saw it was against the law
mommy look down and spit on the ground
every time my name gets mentioned the
Papa said it oh if I get that boy and
won't stick them in the House of
Detention well I'm on my way I don't
know where I'm going I'm on my way I'm
taking my time but I don't know where
save the queen a corona see me and Julio
down by the schoolyard see me only on
our mattress whoo yeah
[Music]
good Laure keep going
good
one keep going
[Music]
yeah go for it thank you
like that's good that's good
and the same on this one
that's good
[Music]
yep if we can just go through
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
good
these are words these are actual words
we are checking the audio sync with the
video and I am saying words I will
continue to say words until shin says
cool Chris you're good okay great bye
mr. Mehra thanks for hospitality then to
all they looked at officials that are
here
ivory the ingredients I can't breathe I
can't breathe
George Floyd's last words but they
didn't die with him they're still being
heard
I could went all across this nation they
speak to a nation where too often just
the color of your skin put your life at
risk they speak to a nation where more
than 100,000 people have lost their
lives the virus and 40 million of file
for unemployment with the
disproportionate number of those deaths
and job losses concentrated in black and
brown communities and they speak to a
nation where every day millions of
people and millions not at the moment of
losing their life but in the course of
living their life are saying to
themselves I can't breathe it's a
wake-up call to our nation in my view
it's for all of us and I mean all of us
it's not the first time we've heard
those words they're the same words we
heard from Eric garner when his life was
taken away six years ago but it's time
to listen to those words to try to
understand them to respond to them
respond with action a country is crying
out for leadership leadership the q9s
leadership that brings us together
leadership that can recognize pain and
deep grief of communities that have had
a knee on their neck for a long time
there's no place for violence no place
for looting or destroying property or
burning churches or destroying
businesses many of them built by the
very people of color who are the first
time and their lives are beginning to
realize their dreams and build wealth
for their family
nor is it acceptable for our police
sworn to protect and serve all people
the escalate tension resort to excessive
violence we need to distinguish between
legitimate peaceful protests and
opportunities to violent destruction we
have to be vigilant about the violence
that's being done by this incumbent
president to our economy and to the
pursuit of justice when peaceful
protesters dispersed in order for a
president a president from the doorstep
of the people's house the White House
using tear gas and flash grenades in
order to stage a photo-op
a photo-op and one of the most historic
churches in the country or at least in
Washington DC we can be forgiven for
believing the president's more interest
in the in in power than in principle
weren't just serving the passions of his
base than the needs of the people in his
care for that's what the presidency is
the duty to care to care for all of us
not just those who vote for us but all
of us not just our donors but all of us
the president held up the Bible at Saint
John's Church yesterday I just wish he
opened it once in a while instead of
brandishing it if he opened it he could
have learned something they're all
called to love one another as we love
ourselves it's really hard work but it's
the work of America Donald Trump is
interested in doing that work instead
he's preening and sweeping away all the
guardrails that law protected our
democracy guardrails that have helped
make possible this nation's path to a
more perfect union a union that
constantly requires reform and
rededication and yes the protest from
voices that are mistreated ignored left
out or left behind
but it is a union be worth fighting for
and that's why I'm running for president
in editions of the Bible the president
might also want to open the US
Constitution lesson while if he did he'd
find a thing called the First Amendment
and what it says and beginning it says
the right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition their
government for redress of grievances
that's kind of an essential notion
building of this country mr. president
that's America that's America no horses
rising up on their hind legs to push
back peaceful protest not using the
American military to move against the
American people this is a nation of
values our freedom to speak is a
cherished knowledge that lives inside
every American almost from the time
you're a kid we're not allow any
president to quiet our voice we all let
those who see this as an opportunity to
sow chaos throw up a smoke screen to
distract us some very real religious and
legitimate grievances at the heart of
these protests we can't we can't leave
this moment I can't leave this moment
thinking that we can once again turn
away and do nothing I can't do that this
time
I just can the moment has come for our
nation to deal with systemic racism to
deal with the growing economic inequity
that exists in our nation to deal with
the denial of the promise of this nation
made to so many you know I've said from
the outset of this election that we're
in the battle for the soul of this
nation we are in the battle for the soul
but we believe that maybe most
importantly who we want to be it's all
stake that's truer today than it has
ever been at least in my lifetime
and it's this urgency it's in this
urgency we can find a path forward now
the history of this nation teaches us
that in some of our darkest moments of
despair we've made some of our greatest
progress some of our darkest moments 13
14 15 therm Emma's followed the Civil
War the greatest economic growth in
world history grew out of the Great
Depression Civil Rights Act of 1964 and
65 OD Rights Act of 65 came and the
tracks of bull Connor's vicious dogs
to paraphrase Reverend barber it's the
morning we find hope it's in the morning
or we find hope only more but it's going
to take more than talk we've had talked
before we've had protests before we've
gotten our vow to make this at least an
area of action and reverse the systemic
racism with a long overdue concrete
changes the action will not be completed
but in the first hundred days of my
presidency if I'm fortunate enough to be
elected or even to my entire term it's
going to take the work of a generation
but if this agenda will take time to
complete it should not wait for the
first hundred days of my presidency to
get started a down payment on what is
long overdue should come now should come
immediately I call on the Congress to
act this month on measures that would be
the first step in this direction
starting with real police reform
Congressman Jefferies has a bill to
outlaw choke holes Congress should put
it on the President's desk
in the next few days.there other
measures a soft transferring weapons of
war to police forces improve oversight
and accountability to create a model use
of force standard that also should be
made law this month no more excuses no
delays if Mitch McConnell can bring in
the United States Senate to confirm
Trump's unqualified judicial nominees
who will run roughshod over our
Constitution now it's time to pass
legislation we'll give true meaning to
our constitutional promise of equal
protection under the law looking ahead
in the first hundred days of my
presidency I've committed to creating a
national police oversight Commission
I've long believed we need real
community policing we need each and
every Police Department of the country
to understand a comprehensive review of
the Undertaker conference review of
their hiring their training through
de-escalation some have already done it
somehow are in a process of doing it the
federal government should give give the
cities and states the tools and the
resources they need to implement reforms
more police officers meet the higher
standards of the procession most of them
do it all the more reason why bad cops
should be dealt with severely and
swiftly we all need to take a hard look
at the culture to allows for the
senseless tragedies that keep happening
and we need to learn from the cities and
the precincts that are getting it right
we know though we have in order to have
true American justice we need economic
justice as well pure tool is there's
much to be done as a media step Congress
should act should act now to rectify
racial inequities that allow Cova 19
recovery funds to be diverted from where
they live I'll be setting forth my
general economic justice and opportunity
in the weeks and months ahead but it
begins with health care health care
should be a right not a privilege the
quickest route to universal coverage in
this country is to expand on Obama care
we can do it we should do it but this
president even now
in the midst of a public health crisis
with massive unemployment as well wants
to destroy him he doesn't care how many
millions Americans will be heard because
he consumed with his blinding he going
to comes to Barack Obama President Obama
the presidency withdraw his lawsuit to
strike down Obamacare and the Congress
should prepare to pass the Act I
proposed to expand Obama care to
millions more so everyone's covered
these last few months we've seen
America's true heroes health care
workers Doc's nurses delivery truck
drivers grocery store workers you know
we've come up with a new phrase for them
essential workers essential workers but
we need to do more than praise them we
need to pay them we need to pay them
because they weren't clear before it's
clear now this country wasn't built by
Wall Street bankers and CEOs and was
built by the great American middle class
which is built by unions and our
essential workers you know I know
there's enormous fear and uncertainty
and anger in the country I understand I
know so many Americans are suffering
suffering loss of a loved one suffering
economic hardship wondering can I feed
my family tomorrow what's going to
happen suffer under the weight of a
generation after generation after
generation of hurt inflicted on people
of color and black brown and Native
communities in particularly like many of
you I know what it means to grieve my
losses are not the same as losses felt
by so many but I know what it feels like
when you think you can't go on I know
what it means to have that black hole in
your chest where your grief is being
sucked into it just a few days ago mark
the fifth anniversary of my son most
passing cancer
they're still moments when the pain is
so great it feels no different than the
day I sat in that bed as he passed away
but I also know that the best way to
bear loss and pain is to turn it into
that anger and anguish in the purpose
and Americans know what our purpose is
as a nation it has to be guided has to
be guided guided us from the very
beginning nelliston reported the day
that President John F Kennedy was
assassinated little Yolanda King came
home from school to Lenin jumped in her
daddy's arms and said Oh daddy she said
now we're never going to get our freedom
her daddy was reassuring strong and
brave he said no don't worry baby it's
gonna be okay it's gonna be all right
amid the violence and fear dr. King he
persevered he was driven by his dream of
a nation where justice runs down like
water and righteousness like a mighty
stream
then 119 68 hate cut him down in Memphis
two days before dr. King was murdered he
gave a final Sunday sermon to Washington
don't worry told us that though the arc
of the moral universe is long
they said it bends towards justice and
we know we can bend it because we have
we have to believe that still that's our
purpose it's been our purpose in the
very beginning to become a nation where
all men and women are not only created
equal but they're treated equally
not just crazy who would treat it
equally to become a nation defined in
dr. King's words not only by the absence
of tension by the presence of justice
it's not enough just a not attention but
justice today in America is hard to keep
faith that justice is his hand I know
that you know that pain is raw pain is
real the president United States must be
part of the solution not the problem
but this president today is part of the
problem and accelerates it when he
tweeted the words when the looting
starts the shooting starts they weren't
the words of the president they're words
of a racist Miami police chief in the
60s when he tweeted the protesters quote
would have been greeted with the most
vicious dogs when people would have been
really hurt end of quote
they weren't the words of a president
they were the kind of words Bull Connor
would have used unleashing his dogs on
innocent women and children
you know the American story is a story
about action and reaction that's
actually works we can't be naive about
it
I wish I could say that hate began with
Donald Trump and with him it didn't and
it won't American history is in a fairy
tale with a guaranteed happy ending the
battle for the soul of this nation has
been a constant push and pull for more
than 240 years a tug of war between the
American ideal that were all created
equal in the harsh reality that racism
has long torn us apart the honest truth
is that both elements are part the
American character both Ellen
at our best the American ideal wins out
but it's never a rout it's always a
fight but the battle is never fully won
but we can't ignore the truth that we're
out our best when we open our hearts
rather than clinch our fists
Donald Trump has turned this country
into a battlefield riven by old
resentments and fresh fears he thinks
division helps him because narcissism
has become more important than the
nation's well-being that he leads I ask
every American I mean this in the bottom
I'll ask every American look at where we
are now and think anew is this who we
are is this what we want to be is this
if we want to pass on to our children
and our grandchildren fear anger
finger-pointing rather the pursuit of
happiness and competence and anxiety
self-absorption selfishness or do we
want to be the America we know we can be
the America we know in our hearts we
could be it should be look I look at the
presidency as a very big job and nobody
will get it right every time and I won't
either
but I promise you this I won't traffic
in fear and division
I won't fan the flames of hate I'll seek
to heal the racial wounds that have long
plagued our country not use them for
political gain I'll do my job and I will
take responsibility I won't blame others
I'll never forget I will never forget I
promise you this job is not about me
it's about you it's about us the work
not only to rebuild the nation but build
it better than it was we're the only
nation of the world that goes through
crisis and comes out better to build a
better future
that's what America does to build a
better future we build the future it may
in fact be the most American thing to do
build the future we hunger for Liberty
the way Harriet Tubman and Frederick
Douglass did we thirst for the vote like
susan b anthony and Ella Baker and John
Lewis did we strive to explore the Stars
cure disease make an imperfect Union
more perfect than his been we make him
up short but at our best we try my
fellow Americans were facing a
formidable enemies they include not only
the coronavirus and the terrible impact
from the lives and livelihoods but also
the selfishness and fear that have
loomed over our national life for the
last three years and I choose those
words advisedly selfishness and feared
defeating those enemies requires us to
do our duty and that Duty includes
remembering who we should be who we
should be we should be the America of
FDR and Eisenhower of Rosa Parks and
Martin Luther King jr. of Jonas Salk and
Neil Armstrong we should be the America
that cherishes life liberty and courage
and above all we should be the American
that chose to each other each and every
one of us you know we're a nation in
pain we must lot but our pain destroy us
we're a nation enraged
we can't love out our rage consume us
we're a nation that's exhausted but we
will not allow our exhaustion defeatist
as president it's my commitment to all
of you to lead on these issues and to
listen because I truly believe in my
heart of hearts we can't overcome
we stand together finally as one America
over eyes stronger than we were before
we'll move that art closer to justice
we'll reach out to one another so speak
out for one another and please please do
us recently been happening take care of
one another this is the United States of
America there's never been anything
we've been unable to do when we set our
mind to do it and we've done it together
together United that's where you are at
our best and God bless you all
I'm going to God protect our troops
[Applause]
[Music]
there is simply much no justification
whatsoever we have seen most clearly in
recent weeks the double standard that's
around that you know there are riots in
the United States we see how local
governments reacted and then in Hong
Kong when we had similar riots we also
saw what position they adopted then
there is simply much no justification
whatsoever for any government any
economy to impose sanctions on Hong Kong
as a result of a very legitimate process
of the central government the central
authorities taking this decision to
enact laws for Hong Kong's who better
protect national security
[Music]
and as their president I will fight to
keep them safe I will fight to protect
you I am your president of law and order
and an ally of all peaceful protesters
the greatest country in the world thank
you very much everybody keep it nice and
safe what's crazy at the beginning
I'm symptomatic right now a field tile
with little dry cough long ultrasound is
really useful in copied was so eagerly
waiting the long before returning back
to my hospital that is the waiting sin
forever to me we have to consider social
media as a new way alternative way to
learn is is the best way to share
experiences globally I had to get over
the laptop at some point pass all my
family all the members in my in my house
we gradually we got this he at some
point so the first one was me but then
the second with was another relative and
the third week was my wife so we have to
change the room to from the isolate the
room that we lived for for the isolation
to a different member each week now I
can share my screen with my presence as
well I can't be more empathic with them
after I've recovered I was able to go
back to my position at the front lines
of the merchants department and after
that I scan more than 200 patients with
copied so what I learned in this process
allow me to better understand the DC
five percent of the population in space
had gone through the infection so I'm
not you someone special
disinformation alternative facts fake
news no matter what you call it it boils
down to who you believe which
information you think is true what's
real enter China where the first case of
the novel coronavirus appeared and now
the target of intense American
disinformation claims I can tell you
that there is a significant amount of
evidence that this came from that
laboratory in Gaeseong Tenjin pudding
should a late confident reading
attention yes should change down your
kuan-yin trivial attention to be clear
US intelligence agencies do not believe
the coronavirus was created by humans or
genetically modified in China meanwhile
the EU published a summary outlining
covert social media ups by the Chinese
government including buying propaganda
Adams showing China as a leader in
combating covet 19 and big text response
to all of this mixed as usual pressing
mostly in what those platforms see as
harmful to their users Facebook and
Instagram label what they consider
misinformation and remove content deemed
dangerous Facebook Twitter and the
Google owned YouTube have pulled
government posts before including those
by the Brazilian President for sharing
misleading information related to the
therapeutic use of the anti malaria drug
hydroxychloroquine to treat home at 19
Twitter is continuing to add new
fact-checking labels to hundreds of
tweets including those from President
Trump and messages from Xiao Lu Zhang a
spokesman for China's foreign ministry
needless to say like so many other
things so far in 2020 it did not
well Trump responded via tweet
threatening to regulate or shudder
social media companies entirely Trump
issued an executive order that seeks to
strip Twitter and other social media
platforms of liability protections for
users posts various posts labeled by
Twitter were posted on Trump's Facebook
page without any warning or label I
don't think that Facebook or internet
platforms in general should be our doors
of truth twitch Twitter CEO responded
this does not make us an arbiter of
truth our intention is to connect the
dots of conflicting statements and show
the information and dispute so people
can judge for themselves there has to be
justice there has to be protest we have
to be heard we have to move forward
strategically we have to move forward
smart we have to move forward tedious
and we have to be together man how are
we doing it
you
talking about how sports is fair would
have been talk about how you know it's
sports is where you bring people
together it's everybody's you know it's
an inclusive thing but when it we talk
about our own personal battles outside
of sports there's a lot of people that
are silent on issues and they're
important issues they're issues that
have been going on for hundreds of years
and we need that same type of team
mentality to be brought to issues
outside of our sport
[Music]
getting gas in Caracas is almost
impossible because of a severe food
shortage due to years of mismanagement
lack of investment and corruption in a
country with the largest oil reserves I
try to do it last week but fail I spent
a whole night in a queue of cars in
hopes of pumping gas in the morning only
a few cars are allowed to do it by the
soldiers that control every single gas
station in Caracas people can only pump
gas two days a week according to their
license plate several people in the
light told me they had tried to fill
their tanks for up to four nights
without succeeding how is this possible
in an oil country what's the common
complaint at 5:00 a.m. after spending
the whole night on the street only 20
people were allowed to pump gas at that
point there were over 100 cars there
past 9:00 a.m. I left in disappointment
my cars tank is now empty in the middle
of a quarantine due to coronavirus in
the meantime the French had may were way
Tomita drivers with daughters were
bribing the officers patrolling the land
the world was that $100 will get you
very close to the front
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay
do you know why I'm under arrest sir why
why am i under arrest
[Music]
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay
do you I am under arrest sir why why am
i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
there is simply much no justification
whatsoever we have seen most clearly in
recent weeks the double standard that's
around that you know there are riots in
the United States we see how local
governments reacted and then in Hong
Kong when we had similar riots we also
saw what position they adopted then
there is simply much no justification
whatsoever for any government any
economy to impose sanctions on Hong Kong
as a result of a very legitimate process
of the central government the central
authorities taking this decision to
enact laws for Hong Kong's who better
protect national security
[Music]
and as their president I will fight to
keep them safe I will fight to protect
you
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of all peaceful protesters
the greatest country in the world thank
you very much everybody keep it nice and
safe
was crazy at the beginning
I'm symptomatic right now field tile
with little dry cough lung ultrasound is
really useful in copied was so eagerly
waiting long before returning back to my
hospital that is the waiting sin forever
to me we have to consider social media
as a new way alternative way to learn is
is the best way to share experiences
globally I had to get over the laptop at
some point pass all my family all the
members in my in my house we gradually
we got this he at some point so the
first one was me but then the second
with was another relative and the third
week was my wife so we have to change
the route to from the isolate the room
that we lived for the isolation to a
different member each week now I can
share my screen with with my presence as
well I can't be more empathic with them
after I recover I was able to go back to
my position at the front lines of the
emergency department and after that I
scan more than 200 patients with copied
so what I learned in this process allow
me to better understand the disease
five percent of the population in Spain
had gone through the infection so I'm
not you someone special
disinformation alternative facts pink
news no matter what you call it it boils
down to who you believe which
information you think is true once we
enter China where the first case of the
novel coronavirus appeared and now the
target of intense American
disinformation claims I can tell you
that there is a significant amount of
evidence that this came from that
laboratory in Gaeseong dungeon putting
in late computing treating
attention yes should change town your
Pony and trillion attention to be clear
US intelligence agencies do not believe
the corona virus was created by humans
or genetically modified in China
meanwhile the EU published a summary
outlining covert social media ups by the
Chinese government including buying
propaganda Adams showing China as a
leader in combating covet 19 and Big Tex
response to all of this mixed as usual
pressing mostly in what those platforms
see as harmful to their users Facebook
and Instagram label what they consider
misinformation and remove content deemed
dangerous Facebook Twitter and the
Google owned YouTube have pulled
government posts before including those
by the Brazilian President for sharing
misleading information related to the
therapeutic use of the anti malaria drug
hydroxychloroquine to treat Co vat19
Twitter is continuing to add new
fact-checking labels to hundreds of
tweets including those from President
Trump and messages from Xiao Lu Zhang a
spokesman for China's foreign ministry
needless to say like so many other
things so far in 2020 it did not
well Trump responded via tweet
threatening to regulate or shudder
social media companies entirely Trump
issued an executive order that seeks to
strip Twitter and other social media
platforms of liability protections for
users posts various posts labeled by
Twitter were posted on Trump's Facebook
page without any warning or label I
don't think that Facebook or Internet
platforms in general should be arbiters
of truth to which Twitter CEO responded
this does not make us an arbiter of
truth our intention is to connect the
dots of conflicting statements and show
the information and dispute so people
can judge for themselves there has to be
justice there has to be protest we have
to be heard we have to move forward
strategically we have to move forward
smart we have to move forward tedious
and we have to be together man how are
we doing it
you
talking about how sports disparity have
been talked about how you know it's
Sports is where you bring people
together it's everybody's you know it's
an inclusive thing but when it we talk
about our own personal battles outside
of sports there's a lot of people that
are silent on issues and they're
important issues they're issues that
have been going on for hundreds of years
and we need that same type of team
mentality to be brought to issues
outside of our sport
[Music]
getting gas in Caracas is almost
impossible because of a severe food
shortage due to years of mismanagement
lack of investment and corruption in a
country with the largest oil reserves I
try to do it last week but fail I spent
a whole night in a queue of cars in
hopes of pumping gas in the morning only
a few cars are allowed to do it by the
soldiers that control every single gas
station in Caracas people can only pump
gas two days a week according to their
license plate several people in the
light told me they had tried to fill
their tanks for up to four nights
without succeeding how is this possible
in an oil country what's the common
complaint at 5:00 a.m. after spending
the whole night on the street only 20
people were allowed to pump gas at that
point there were over 100 cars there
past 9:00 a.m. I left in disappointment
my cars tank is now empty in the middle
of a quarantine due to coronavirus in
the meantime the French had may were way
Tomita drivers with daughters were
bribing the officers patrolling the land
the world was that $100 will get you
very close to the front
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay do you know why I'm
under arrest sir why am i under arrest
[Music]
move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay do you know why I'm
under arrest sir why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
there is simply no justification
whatsoever we have seen most clearly in
recent weeks the double standard that's
around that you know there are riots in
the United States we see look how local
governments reacted and then in Hong
Kong when we had similar riots we also
saw what position they adopted then
there is simply much no justification
whatsoever for any government any
economy to impose sanctions on Hong Kong
as a result of a very legitimate process
of the central government the central
authorities taking this decision to
enact laws for Hong Kong's who better
protect national security
[Music]
and as their president I will fight to
keep them safe I will fight to protect
you
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of all peaceful protesters the
greatest country in the world thank you
very much everybody
keep it nice and safe what's crazy at
the beginning
I'm symptomatic right now field tile
with little dry cough long ultrasound is
really useful in copied was so eagerly
waiting the long before returning back
to my hospital that is the waiting sing
forever to me we have to consider social
media as a new way alternative way to
learn is is the best way to share
experiences globally I had to get over
the laptop at some point pass all my
family all the members in my in my house
we gradually we got this he at some
point so the first one was me but then
the second with was another relative and
the third week was my wife so we have to
change the room to from the isolate the
room that we lived or the isolation to a
different member each week now I can
share my experiment with my presence as
well I can't be more empathic with them
after I recover I was able to go back to
my position at the front lines of the
merchant department and after that I
scan more than 200 patients with copy so
what I learned in this process allow me
to further understand that is he five
percent of the population in Spain had
gone through the infection so I'm not
someone special
[Music]
disinformation alternative facts think
news no matter what you call it it boils
down to who you believe which
information you think is true once we
enter China where the first case of a
novel coronavirus appeared and now the
target of intense American
disinformation claims I can tell you
that there is a significant amount of
evidence that this came from that
laboratory in Gaeseong engine putting
sugar in late computing treating
attention yes should change down your
pony entries yet engine to be clear US
intelligence agencies do not believe the
corona virus was created by humans or
genetically modified in China meanwhile
the EU published a summary outlining
covert social media ops by the Chinese
government including buying propaganda
Adams showing China as a leader in
combating covet 19 and Big Tex response
to all of this mixed as usual resting
mostly in what those platforms see as
harmful to their users Facebook and
Instagram label what they consider
misinformation and remove content deemed
dangerous Facebook Twitter and the
Google owned YouTube have pulled
government posts before including those
by the Brazilian President for sharing
misleading information related to the
therapeutic use of the anti malaria drug
hydroxychloroquine to treat home at 19
Twitter is continuing to add new
fact-checking labels to hundreds of
tweets including those from President
Trump and messages from Xiao Lu Zhang a
spokesman for China's foreign ministry
needless to say like so many other
things so far in 2020 it did not
well Trump responded via tweet
threatening to regulate or shudder
social media companies entirely Trump
issued an executive order that seeks to
strip Twitter and other social media
platforms of liability protections for
users posts various posts labeled by
Twitter were posted on Trump's Facebook
page without any warning or label I
don't think that Facebook or Internet
platforms in general should be arbiters
of truth to which Twitter CEO responded
this does not make us an arbiter of
truth our intention is to connect the
dots of conflicting statements and show
the information and dispute so people
can judge for themselves there has to be
justice there has to be protest we have
to be heard we have to move forward
strategically we have to move forward
smart we have to move forward tedious
and we have to be together man how are
we doing it
you
talking about how sports is forever
would have been talked about how you
know it's sports is where you bring
people together it's everybody's you
know it's an inclusive thing but when it
we talk about our own personal battles
outside of sports there's a lot of
people that are side alone issues and
they're important issues they're issues
that have been going on for